all right we are live with
Emerson
[Laughter]
hooray hello hello hello Atlas welcome
to the
show thank you for having me it's pretty
epic yeah it is it's so exciting yeah
I've been watching your
Rise
um oh rise yeah rise such
a your content production has gotten so
cool like the I was mentioning to you
like those
documentaries style looks so beautiful
and um just the just the direct sort of
uh cutting of of Duality for the um for
whoever is asking is also very clear and
clean and
um
yeah um hi hi live chat good to see
y'all um hello live chat yeah I don't
see it but yeah that's something that
I'll do is I'll bring it up eventually
into the screen where we feature guests
so that you can also yeah yeah no
worries this is cool yeah yeah so let's
uh let's yeah let's dive in I mean I me
obviously um non-duality points to what
can't be said but maybe um you can share
with us uh how you say what can't be
said to in your in your
sessions um so what what is being
expressed cannot really be expressed
it's unspeakable yet it appears as this
expression yet it appears is still
speaking for no apparent reason I mean
simply just as it is and and there's
nothing that's needed everything already
it is and uh and this whole conversation
is completely
pointless and meaningless but it's a
liveness appearing as this whatever it
is really simple yeah it's simply not to
um again it can't really be said
anything that can be um expressed is
just an expression of something that is
ineffable something that cannot really
be gred so it's not about in the
understanding it's not in the
comprehension because no matter what he
said or not said it simply already
is yeah yeah or something like that
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah I mean and this is the thing is
that there's really nowhere to go or
nothing to say no one to say it
um and this is why these things are
always very funny because it is it is
it's uh I usually get get into Giggles
because it's really absurd to speak to
no
one yet it appears as there's someone
you know what I'm saying it's just it's
just this constant constant appearance
of something that cannot really be
comprehended and yet comprehension tries
to come in and tries to say of what this
is although it can never really be said
so it seems like all of these words are
just like flurries of something that's
already clear it's like a it's like a a
rain fall of something that's already
done
yeah that that um that sort of grabbing
um to know a function that's sort of the
the thing that's under undermined by the
message yeah it it's it's it it's
completely in graspable yet even the
grasping of it is just what seems to be
cing right so it's it's just uh it's
just the whole pointlessness of this
this seeming
conversation but yet it's it's just play
really it's just play and and it's not
nothing really that serious yet there's
a lot of seriousness in talking about
this I don't know if you've noticed and
I don't know how many interviews you've
done about is that there seems to be a
lot of seriousness sometimes and there's
an eruption of laughter that appears
right because it's just it's just you
know it goes serious well there's really
nothing you know yes yes yes yes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah how and how can um what's
already here be an achievement or an
attainment is is another fun way
of saying or like how can what's already
hearing this voice or watching this
video which is already nothing and
already wholeness how can that possibly
make um a a move to to get something to
become what it already
is yeah it it doesn't really and that's
the conundrum right because it doesn't
really in no matter how sincere a
speaker in trying to express that over
and over again there's still going to be
a trying to get what's being said and it
becomes this this knowing that there's
someone that knows or there's no one so
it goes into this this this
um for a lack of better word a um a
conclusion it becomes a getting it
becomes you know that there's someone
there there's no one there it becomes
this but all of that is just really
noise it's really noise everything is
just no noise and what is already
completely silent and the noise and the
static that comes along it's fun it's
fun trying to get this because
it's it's just a play but it cannot be
it's not about getting something that
already is so we can talk here for hours
and hours and questions might arise
about what's being spoken about but it
will always be the same that it's
already the case and there's nothing to
get and no one to attain it simple it's
a simple
yet yet that can be you know can be a
conversation for a couple of hours yeah
that there's nothing to get there's no
one to get and uh and then how how is
that possible and it becomes just this
this uh complete um um blah blah blah
blah
blah if you know what I
mean what's
also come up more and more beautifully
is that this message sort of um
appearing in physicality has been
showing up like um the decentralization
of basic needs infrastructures so the
way that it seems to be manifest at
least here is like um water food new
Energy new housing a new communities um
people being free to have have joy have
play have creativity to not have to sell
the apparent time for apparent money to
pay for basic needs and so that's why
this da home DA has come up as you know
this main vehicle for for that and
that's just how this is so how has it
been like over there um with that
everything is just a a flow of nothing
you know so there's really no um there's
really no need because everything just
risis everything is just an appearance
and um and it's just autonomous right so
it's just this seemingly happening but
it's not really happening for anyone but
seemingly it happens to whatever reason
it is so everything is allowed right so
it's not in a in a survival or seeking
mechanism anymore it's just what is and
uh whatever seems to appear it's just
whatever seems to appear and it's not
about trying to get something anymore
trying to attain something anymore so
the getting the wanting the Desiring the
greed of it all just seemingly drops
away for no re reason whatsoever right
so it's just this it's just this
wholeness I don't even want to call it
that let's just say
contentment that's a better word there's
a contentment no matter
what talk tell me about the Dow I um I
have I wanted to look at the website but
I think I ran out of
time
sorry all good
Tommy
um
yeah I love what you just said briefly
there there was
just this autonomous flow of perfection
and freedom yeah yeah and that's why
that's why this um decentralized
autonomous organization or Dows oh cool
that's what that yeah that's what that
it's a it's a term from um web 3 and
that's what's the evolution of the
internet so the internet's not owned by
anyone it's like a decentralized
autonomous thing and then the evolution
of that is web 3 and web 3 uh has
emerged more most prominently with
things like Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
yeah and what those have tried to do is
um take out centralized governments in
Fiat currencies of of nation states and
so yeah so the idea is that anyone can
um uh have this unit of value and then
have that unit of value be sent across
the world without a middleman and yeah
Etc but now the thing is is that even
that and this is on the home da website
we have like a whole evolution of
currency graphic that we that we worked
on because what's beyond Bitcoin that
we've created with this um with the the
mechanism that is this home Dow is home
tokens which are backed so bitcoin's not
backed by anything but home tokens are
backed by real world assets like clean
renewable energy or water wells or food
forests or modern housing or um just
anything that is um like tangibly a
basic
need and so now um the idea is is like
okay we can
Dow
from a place that is empty and from a
place that is whole from a place that is
fulfilled from a place that is the
absence of that that Center Point that
wants to yeah yeah yep and so well it's
kind of like what's being talked about
you know this this seeming nonduality
even you it's just the name really is
just it it it it's decentralized it
doesn't have an authority figure it
doesn't have a knowledge it it's not a
learning it's not it's not something
that's passed on even because it already
is so it's it's it's a well it's not
really a model but seemingly it's a
model that is complete unconditional
Freedom um and and and what's being
expressed is not really reliant on
spirituality it has nothing to do with
spirituality even it's just the it's
it's if everything was silenced you know
for a bleep of a second then everything
already is that there's nothing to get
nothing to know but the silence that
that we speak of is is already yeah and
that's what seemingly is is sought for
is that that absence the nothing you can
call silence nothing whatever yes um but
it's not even a word because the moment
that the word gets introduced to what's
being spoken about it becomes a knowing
right so this is the unknowing of of
what seems to be known as just um as
irrelevant yes so everything that's
known is irrelevant so there's this
decentralization it's almost like the
the uh the uh The Apocalypse of knowing
yes the uh the Armageddon of all the
teachers that's know and it's and it's
it's it's the rise of the Anarchy and
the wildness of just this yes yes yes
yes oh
yeah
oh so it's it's like a it's like um it's
like a rebellion to to structures and
but there's no one rebelling yes
anything that's structured anything
that's known anything that's that's
that's held on to it's the uh it's the
uh the death of all of the Sacred cows
and it's the death of me basically
because the me seems to hold all of
these ideas and makes it into something
when it's actually nothing
yes it's always
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing and from a person coming from
knowing this will sound really really
insane yeah yeah but in but knowing
actually is insanity because it's two
yeah yeah
yeah it appears it appears so insane in
the appearance when there's that
uh there was a video that was created
recently on the channel about separation
porn that was sort of the way that it
was
described I like
that it's all like some it's a fight
yeah against an imaginary other
yeah and so that's in
Saye and perfect it's made of of the
beautiful Freedom that it's crazy it's
Beau it's it's just wildness right it's
it's it's it's wild it's it's it's this
obliteration of everything that holds
back that freedom it's it's it's because
there's no separate there's nothing
separate from freedom freedom is just
Freedom appearing as whatever um and
it's just uh it's it's unthinkable
Unthinkable yet it appears as thoughts
as thinking or whatever but that's just
an appearance of
[Laughter]
course
wow yeah when we when we first started
um chitchatting before we started
streaming
um you you you shared that um that you
had watched some of the recent content
and felt like we had started to use some
of the similar ter
terminology which which I which I was
like yeah that's right man it it yeah um
did you see the the the
nword yes that's the one that's the one
oh that's F you know I don't usually
research you know before I get us so
that it's fresh right so that there's
but I'm like maybe I'll click on this
one while I'm I'm trying to adjust my
screen here I'm like oh the nword um
let's click on that one and there's just
this poppable Freedom right and and what
seems to be spoken about in comparison
to you know I think you were someone
prompted me about you because you
interviewed someone that we know and
what a difference man
yeah yeah and again all all before there
was a lot of correction that happened
but it's it's it's just ridiculous to
correct something that already is isn't
it right yeah right and then when when
when and a character character you know
pretends although it's innocence as well
to know something then it creates this
position and it creates this knowing it
creates this pedestal and then it
creates an infer inferior when there's
nothing Superior or inferior it's just
another idea of what is so all of these
ideas are being you know thrown at you
know uh when I was watching you before
and I was like oh no oh no but it's also
what is and then I saw your nword with
the shirtless nword there and I was like
yes free the nipple yeah free the
nipple exactly exactly yes yes oh that's
and it's just wildness it's it's uh when
when I was seeking you know there was so
much Ser seriousness right when I was I
was a teacher before and I became super
serious right right when everything just
seemingly fell apart you know everything
that was held on to everything that was
um sacred everything that was divine
everything that was the truth the
absolute cracked into pieces and what
was left was just this an unutterable
Freedom it is in everything it's not
held by someone it's not held for
someone and it cannot be corrected it
cannot be known it cannot be um even
talking about it is mood right so but
yet here it is talking about it you know
and freeing the nipple and talking about
the nword
[Laughter]
um and and there's no more barrier
there's no more boundaries there's no no
Atlas And there's no em really yes and
and and and um yeah what a what a huge
different because when when when you
messaged me I was talking to someone and
I was like oh yeah he interviewed this
person this character and I was like oh
I wonder if he's gonna be serious and
everything I was like thinking I
want I wonder I wonder this like there
there's there's a lot of blessedness
because this was always very goony it's
all oh there's the thumbs up where are
these what is this fireworks oh my gosh
I have to look into these OBS animations
or however these are coming up they're
so cool whatow and they just
spontaneously happen I think you have to
do a prompt you know something like that
and then it and then it shows up yeah or
maybe not there we go yeah oh cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's so interesting man
um and I love how it came up during that
goonin cuz that's right yeah there's
always been that goonin and it's
actually seen so much in children in
innocence in children there's always
such goonin it's it's it's always
impossible to try to be able to
rationalize or understand how that
innocence is like all over the place and
chaotic and anarchic and Wild and Free
yeah um and actually in the in the you
know you have a dog that's about a year
or so old and you can see it in the dog
and the cat this oh yeah yeah totally
and and that's what seemed to have you
know um was lost was the uh the adult
the the serious character named Emerson
that wanted to control things wanted to
manipulate things wanted to be right
wanted to win all the debates and all
this kind of stuff and you know you know
because the character was the eldest son
that always was right and and what a
farce that was what a big joke that was
what a what a bully that was that that
that whatever that was and uh and
there's just this um silly Goofy
character that laughs when when when
it's when even when it's not not
appropriate yeah yeah yeah and yeah the
the the the comedic um goonin just comes
up more and more man it does isn't it
it's it's interesting that you said that
there was that older you were the eldest
of the of how many five kids five kids
yeah Asian family too are you are you
Filipino I'm Filipino Filipino yes okay
yes okay and um were you born there or
here I was born in Philippines yeah I
moved to Canada when I was 14 okay yeah
cool cool and then so are your parents
and siblings in Canada then we're all in
Canada so so we all moved here uh in
Canada and I hated it I was just like
what the hell is this because I lived in
a metropolitan and I moved to kind of
like a Ontario where it was like you
know but anyway it was just it was just
funny then everything that I was holding
on to you know our culture and
everything started falling apart
seemingly but that character Emerson
remained as the eldest yes yes even when
I was everything that I did was was that
you know um being in front of audience
being a leader and everything right
right um being a teacher yes and so when
when it started speaking which is by
accident by the way when I started
speaking about this I just really wanted
to be in the background there was
already a lot of clarity and um even
when I was doing nothing media at that
time right there was already no seeking
happening it was just it was already
clear but there was joy in in fanboying
about what is yeah so this is just a
fanboy of what what is that's good way
to say it
too a fanboy fan girl of what is a
fanboy of what is and it can't help
talking about it but right right and and
and there's just this this authenticity
and creativity because it's no longer
controlled by a need right so it's just
comes it just bursts right it's just a
it's just a yeah it's it's it's
passionate it's alive but it also is is
also sees the pointlessness of it all so
it doesn't take it take itself seriously
yes and uh and it's funny because
characters would type a whole bunch of
comments and everything um and but it's
also seen as innocence right it it this
cannot be comprehended and every
question that that arises is try to
understand or comprehend and what's
being talked about but um and I do one
in once and it's kind of funny when I do
one in once right when when everything
just falls apart yes it's so I'm been a
fan of it although there's no one there
right it's just it's just like there's
just this silence and I'm like yes and I
and I ask them like does any does any
thoughts really matter and they're like
no yes you know is there anything
missing no you know it's just it's just
this completeness of something uh is
there a me even there like I can't find
it yes and that's what's so fascinating
because it's already obvious yes but the
words get in the way the ideas the
knowledge that the being right being the
out the character you know being right
and uh um yeah it's it's I was talking
to someone and uh someone basically said
someone was watching your your your
thing um she's the nality Whisperer and
uh she said that you got mentioned in
one of atlas's video about asking you or
whatever and um at first I I I I was
like oh yeah that's the the guy that
interviewed someone and I really thought
it was going to be one of those
conversations that's going to be kind of
like
a what is what is consciousness what is
awareness like why not you know we could
talk about that too um but luckily you
know saying and for you know and and
fortunately it's just this yes it's just
this it's just this um um two kids
playing yes and and it's just a child
childlikeness of this yes because
there's nothing serious really and yeah
yeah and and and it's uh the seriousness
of seeking is is quite
um wow why you so serious right yeah
yeah but it's also what is it's also
what is right so yeah yeah yes exactly
yet yesterday there was a a birthday
Happening Here in the community and so
there was a good amount of people that
gathered in the evening and there was a
conversation that was struck up um and
and so this girl was asking about like
you know what what uh about what just
questions that sort of led to this
basically and yeah and I was just sort
of sharing that like this is sort of the
energy of that like the movement of the
Seeker in its kind of stinky Little Pond
bouncing between experiences trying to
find what's not missing
Etc and then finally after um a bit uh
was sitting on the couch and there was
sort of that just like that unknowing
that really kind of like settled and
that the completeness that is always
already here cuz there was such an
interest from her into like structuring
I want to structure all of my ideas into
courses and I want to teach courses and
and then that from here there was a like
an undermining in terms of just um like
before someone even enters a therapy
session that you would host yeah do you
do you do you can you see how it's it's
nothing that's entering into the therapy
session it's not and and so that there's
it's already empty yes yes yes and and
then then that that there's something
there's something that brought this to
Austin because of
that sharing in a way of that specific
one because there's you can sort of see
that energy in a way kind of like settle
um into the what we've been talking
about as these these goony
kids you know Goonies do you Remember
The Goonies
Sor yeah this is uh there and and like
and there's something there's something
beautiful like you said in the
one-on-one that you do that there's
there's something beautiful about just
that yeah and again there's nothing
needed already right so it's just it's
just almost kind of like a um ripping
out what seems to obscure what already
is right and yes and and and and they'll
say whatever you know whatever they say
or whatever it doesn't change that it's
already the case and um usually it's
it's it's the zapping of belief systems
the zapping of that ideas although no
one zaps it or is just the the the the
the emptiness of the transparency the
transparency right it's it's it's like
you know when somebody's playing in like
hideand-seek and somebody goes okay I
don't want to hideand-seek anymore I'm
like okay let's have a talk well there's
nothing hidden hidden he goes what do
you mean there's nothing hidden um well
there's really nothing hidden because
what seems to be hidden appears in
everything goes I don't get
it it's even that it's whatever it is
you know because there's nothing hidden
it appears in every single thought in
every single feeling in every single and
it's also nothing at the same time it's
the nword
yes and it's not about understanding
nothing too right because that seems to
be another kind like how do I comprehend
nothing you can't right it's nothing and
it's not even nothing right it's not
even that it's it's nothing in what it
it cannot be said exactly yet it appears
in everything that's said that's what I
mean
it seems to be hidden but it appears in
everything yes yeah I love that
[Music]
yeah yeah what what can't be said that
appears in
everything yeah yeah and it's brilliant
right I was like when when when I was
talking to someone about this about
seeking I'm like well played what a long
Con well played wow it's always been
this way yes well played what a well
played sir you know wow and it was just
so yes yes that's that's it all the
suffering that you know of being not
being a able to get out of bed the um
the you know why you know the falling
down on your knees like why is this
happening to me it just becomes this
farce right um and it's but it's it's it
and then you laugh at it because I'm
like oh that's even it even that
suffering that seeming suffering anyway
that um that desperate cry you know or
or or that that falling apart losing
everything um when it was so simple and
I'm like well played and I'm like the
character played it really well too
because it it seemingly seemed that the
character was was completely embroiled
in it yeah right it can't separate
itself from it so so Atlas in the story
of Atlas what happened did did did did
it also fall
apart the seriousness cracked and it
became just this this madness nice nice
oh my gosh yeah that that's what that's
why there's been such a fascination with
that the word contract because it is
just a
con it is but it's not even there
exactly it's not even there it's not
even a contraction yeah yeah exactly
you'll only notice that is a contraction
when there's no contraction meaning
there was no contraction in the
beginning yes it's just this lightness
of being but there's not even a being
it's just likeness but yeah go ahead
sorry oh my
gosh yeah I must attain
wholeness yeah
yeah I will find it through
experiences will you please tell me how
to attain wholeness yes yes yes yes yes
what do you mean it's already the case
yeah
yeah and yet that's there's no agency
right so that's happening without anyone
controlling it yeah you know there
there's this idea that you can
manipulate yourself into this but
there's no one driving the show there's
no one running the show there's not even
a source to this and that's and that's
what's mindboggling that there's no mind
yeah that this is just automatically
happening but that's not even
it yeah that there's really no Center
that there's really no Source there's
really no everything that can be thought
thought about just completely goes down
the drain you're like how about oh
yeah and you're like trying to hold on
to things you're
like there there there's some there's
some one in ones that that people go
like
this
yes because they're trying to find what
can't be grasped they're like holy crow
it's it's it's this it's this it's
impossible but yet it's possibility it's
this is a possibility in the mind but
there's no mind for it to be possible to
so all possibilities are mind
mindmade did I say mind made but there's
no there's no mind because mind is just
a
possibility but it's it's not even
possible and uh and all of this seeming
longing wanting Desiring um and con
contraction it's just this this circling
kind of like clouds that seem to obscure
what's already clear that there's
nothing be beyond the cloud there's
nothing behind it yes
yes would you would you say that in the
sessions um that um what is what is
appearing is sort of the um the asking
for permission to be the nothing that
already is it's kind of funny right um
it it almost seems that way sometimes
right so um but there's no one that can
validate this there's no one that can
invalidate it right because it already
is so even the seeming asking for
permission is already it yes you know it
it's it's like it's like there's no
blessing because there's no one to bless
yes because that's also it and um and
usually usually you know there's
characters that seem to get attracted
that have been seeking for a long long
time you know if usually people that
have 10 years or 20 years of seeking you
know um Madness and crazy and they just
want to end it and it's it's almost like
they just want someone blunt to say well
it's already over I don't know what
you're talking about I don't know what
what what it is that you want because
there's nothing that is needed it's
already this is already it right so from
a session it's just repeatedly saying
over and over and over again um and I
like that uh you know at first I did not
really want to release it but I like the
transparency that there's nothing to get
yeah that there's no Hocus Focus because
what this is is like a sobriety yeah to
all ideas right there's it's a lot of
intoxication with with um you know
trying to be
aware you know or trying to to to settle
in or trying to not move your whatever
you know yeah yeah yeah trying not to
think yeah
yeah and and it's a lot of Correction in
in in spirituality so this is the um the
abrupt the sudden sobriety to what is
being struck sober to what is and um it
is what it is and it's just the in the
most ordinary things it's the most
mundane things it's not the uh and again
there's nothing wrong or right about
people doing stuff you know because
there's no one choosing to do it but the
only things that seem to happen is
there's an intoxication that there's a
next that there's something to happen
next if I do this then eventually
something will fall out or something
will drop yes but there's no me to drop
already yes there's already no self um
to lose or to find so any direction that
that seeking happens to is just it's
it's irrelevant
it's it's
uh it's pointless to do something when
it's already done yep yeah yeah that's
such a fun one for those that appear to
after 10 20 whatever apparent years of
just to it's already done it's already
done yeah it's already done and it's and
it's funny right because it's just
usually the remnant of this you know um
seeking is just this NeverEnding looping
of thinking that there's something to
get there's something to get there's a
me to drop there's a whatever seems to
repeat it's nothing or or whatever but
when it's seen that those are all just
um empty like clouds meaning that
they're completely meaningless and
pointless to irrelevant um when when
it's seen that there's no one thinking
any of this um that there's no one
behind any of this then there's really
no separation even if all the words were
eliminated what is
separation in the absence of
thoughts what's even a thought yeah it's
just it's just yeah yes
[Laughter]
yeah I love that yeah the freedom before
any of the dualistic ideas of separation
or non-separation or a me or no me just
this yeah
yeah there there there's also a seeming
um and again it's just innocence there's
a seeming confusion that there has to be
a no me which is just another idea which
is just another entanglement that needs
to something that needs to happen or
something that needs to be recognized
it's just another
farce and when it's seen that it's all a
joke you know um then whatever seems to
be contracted is just seen as just oh it
was not even
there yeah nothing really happened it's
it's like that that um you know this
this nighttime dream that's heavily
invested with the me right there's for
example in the nighttime dream you
become like a a billionaire or something
and you are um there's this investment
you know it feels absolutely real and
everything that's done seems to be you
know this reality the moment that the
character wakes up um it was none of
that yeah
yeah so the investment in a character is
always empty yeah because the character
is a
dream and that's saying way too much
about
nothing so when did this uh the n-word
and all of this shirtless uh you know
meeting started happening Atlas
let's see if we can get Emerson to show
us some nips oh not
today that's what happing Emerson's like
Emerson's like first you have to take me
to
dinner that not in the first date man
come
on maybe in the next
one I love it I have to grow more hair
holy [__] that's a lot of hair yes yes
check out that I feel inadequate there
for a moment shoulder
[Laughter]
pads so yeah so when so when did did
shortless um you know meeting started
happening here
happened oh well everything that we've
been um chatting about just the last uh
these last streams that's really been
the core of it oh wow yeah it's um this
uh
this summer there was um such a an
obsession with all of these like
thousands of Concepts and ideas and
hundreds hundreds of maps and whatnot
and then um there was just a a real
like you know like that Indescribable
that's been that we've been talking
about and it's just like
so free really and yeah even yeah free
of all of that and that that is that is
its own like kind of like it's it's kind
of like its own heavy like chains and
you know rocks to carry around is um all
of those ideas Concepts Maps identities
labels um ways to try to control or
change the appearance and whatnot and um
it's just like yeah
it's i g to say there there's a there's
a there's a comment in live chat that
says Emerson's having a bad nipple Day
LA
let me
[Laughter]
see this the second second date okay
okay so Emerson said that uh we'll proba
we'll probably we'll have a second we'll
have a second conversation um you know
about
this we'll go on Emerson's Channel and
maybe maybe we'll get some of that some
of that
little oh it's great this whole uh
what it it's also like the dog you know
the dogs the cats the babies the
nakedness um yeah it is this is naked
you know what I'm saying this is this
does not have any kind of costumes or
any kind of um barrier it's just the um
it's the intimacy of what's being talked
about is just there's no more um um
dress
up and and it's it's naked naked more
naked than than the nipples of Atlas um
yeah if you know what I'm talking about
right so it's I I like the way that you
describe it because the way that I
describe it rather than contraction it's
like it's like carrying a backpack full
of frogs that you were thought you were
carrying and then one day you can't find
a backpack you know it's just all of the
concepts all of the ideas all of the all
of the heaviness that seem to have
weighed you down you know that maintains
that there's a you
um all of a sudden you can't find it
it's just nowhere to be found I was
talking to someone basically that that
um maybe after about six months
basically said I didn't know how how
light This was um and and it's not it's
not about attaining something it's
losing everything yes and and including
that shirt there's another there's
another comment in the live chat that
says set Emerson free of shirt
prison
later
later now I love the suspense that
everon building up now it's like that
yeah so so that so that you know well
well if you watch the next episode
there'll be some nipples freed you know
what I'm saying but you can't give it
all yeah find Emerson on only
fans there's a peell for that you
know
[Music]
[Laughter]
will be called like an only fans for
nonduality
[Laughter]
speaker I love it though it's it's like
that um like in the relationship when
the uh when the woman doesn't allow a
penetration right
away that's great it's like Emerson's
like second date
second a thousand push-ups later you
know
exactly they back all buff like so
what's up you
know fake chest hair you know just like
right right hair coming
out
[Laughter]
we but yeah um it get nice and swole
before the second show for sure yeah a
huge pump before this yes right
right you were like uh not yet
yet that's also what's happening you
know what I'm
saying
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
yeah
yeah like so this this sort of this
goony playful free spontaneity Joy all
of
that what what is appearing like there's
um like some sort of like hand handcuffs
that the body is sort of in with uh G
get going and earning money and having
to pay for its basic needs so it's
really exciting feeling into like this
Dow and this this really this liberation
of that enslavement of basic needs and
like what oh yeah yeah yeah that that's
what appears here too right because
there's no more um there's no more Pride
um or desire seemingly that seems to
create this this idea um of of Desiring
I don't know I can't make sense of it
it's it's hard to make sense of
something that's just so direct right so
in the directness of it all everything
is just what is and and there's no more
questioning it there's no continuity
it's just what is and it's not coming
from a place of lack anymore because
when I was seeking that was always what
it was it was a lack lack lack lack it
didn't matter if I had tons of money in
the bank at one point right or or um a
status you know what I'm saying that was
well respected or a legacy that was um
that was maintained or the idea of what
you are so in all of the idea um um
completely falls apart um it's just it's
just what is it's just it's just this um
kind of like what you're saying like go
ahead
yeah yeah there was a really good um
conversation between theovon and Tucker
Carlson on um this past weekend have you
ever watched Theo Van's show
no yeah um and Theo just mentioned that
he a couple years ago had a a really
nice um sort of
um of his rise with um money Fame like
being able to pay for his mortgage that
whole year that kind of thing and he
like felt like it was just this huge
stab because he thought that that was
how he was going to feel
fulfillment yeah and that's sort of the
that's the that's the N that's really
the thing that like that function that
is like it will be when there is that
attained that's really like that oh it's
it's not actually oh but maybe if it's
more what if it's more fall what if it's
more material what if it's more you know
and then it's like it's not that either
and then
that's
yeah yeah and so that's why like being
taken out in a way being taken out and
seeing that there there never was
but being taken out that's that and then
the the the the dawing that
that that
um those basic needs you know being
there and being um being the bodies
being completely free to be joyous and
playful and spontaneous yeah totally
totally those those those are somehow
met for no reason at all without any
effort for some odd reason if you know
what I mean it's uh and again there's no
more no more uh anyone choosing to do
anything so it's just naturally
seemingly occurring um but really empty
at the same time it's just what is it's
it's kind of funny because about um uh
about I think about six months or eight
months ago um this character has been
speaking for about a year about this and
everything um but I was doing it for
free for everybody you know like doing
free one-on ones and everything because
there's just this passion for it and I
had a job before um and then I realized
that for the past year um
um there was uh there's no income coming
in so I decided to take a job you know
what I'm saying but whatever you know
saying because there's really no um no
one choosing to do anything and it's it
doesn't take this speaking really really
seriously so the job paid a lot of money
um but for some odd reason because the
character does not really have a really
good memory
anymore so was it was not good enough
for the job but somehow when that job
you know ended this speaking somehow got
it blew up a little bit there's more
people that you know that that seemingly
listen to the character or whatever and
it was just so unexpected because there
was no trying to survive anything it was
just what is right so there was it's
just this autonomous happening yes yes
and and and just completely surprised
that oh wow this is also what what is so
there's no sense of There's No Lack
anymore I even joked at one point um I
said well if I ended up working at
McDonald's you know you'll hear someone
on on the uh on the speaker there's
really
nothing yeah there'll be a speaker on it
but it it doesn't matter so it doesn't
matter anymore what wealth is what
attainment is you know somehow the basic
needs are met for no reason for whatever
and it's it's not even a doing any
anymore yes yeah yes
yeah yeah
yeah yeah just yeah I what what you just
shared there just to say back that yeah
it this is this is when there's because
if there is doing it yeah then
there's then there's basically entity in
a way or whatever beingness being yeah
yeah there's meing in meing yeah yeah
yeah and um which is okay by the way yes
yes and if there if there's the the
apparent experience of there being a
doer then sure um it's just this but
that there's like
this this what we we've been saying is
the decentralized autonomous flow and
like that it's just
yeah it really it's so impossible to say
but at least this this body's
function is loving the basic needs
decentralization and the freedom that
the
bodies
apparently have from um not needing to
cuz that's the the circles that spin so
often are about
like [__] like got to go earn money to
pay my rent and like that's like that's
a huge part of that spinning and and
then there's there's
like there's never there's never
actually in a way there's never actually
um whatever happened when there was like
yeah this is my my land has this line
and now I'm going to PR privatize and
corporatize the production of houses and
all this kind of stuff all that
apparently happened and so it there's
been a a pretty big um um in a way the
part of that spinning meing is has to do
with that contracted monetary um Bond
bonding for basic needs so it's just
it's exciting it's like the child never
had that the child never had some sort
of having to go earn the basic needs and
so that's what feels like is
is unbinded when there's no having Force
to earn basic needs yeah it's just a
return to innocence that always is
that's basically it it's just the
innocence of everything and um and that
seems to be very evident in everything
that seems to appear there's just this
contracted that there is a lack you know
and that's what propels the seeking is
that there's always a lack there's
something missing and it gets caught up
in this lack um um ideas and um and it
misses out on the fullness of everything
even in the lack um because that's just
an idea so what cannot be comprehended
what cannot be um known is just this
fullness that you know that it does not
need a knowing it does not need a a
grasping because it's already full uh
it's it's without any um without a
second really without any geography
without a two
it's just simply just this appearance um
and it's just what is
yeah
yeah I love that returning to the
Innocence that always was and always is
and um without a to without like a a
journey that had to be taken to to get
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
oh and there there's like another
resonance now with what is like let's
say um whatever Brotherhood or whatever
you want to call you know this is this
is exciting Emerson is really exciting
yeah yeah it is it is it is it's it's
it's it's the non-separateness of it
right so there's just this um there's no
more you know wall seemingly that seems
to be held only by one person and that
person is not even there yeah
yeah oh oh
boy wow what a funny dance that was with
like one that was like inferior and
didn't know and then one that knew and
had a crown and then like was like being
like worshiped in a way and then like
and then that like whole thing
beautifully like when when when the one
that it when there's finally sort of
seeing through through that but also by
nothing but also sort of
like being able to then like reflect
back on like the fless of it already
being it yeah yeah that's also it right
so but that that that seeming play right
was was um it it it I I watched some of
that you know when you were in that play
of of the inferior and and trying to see
if there was someone Superior that can
give you anything was was almost painful
to
watch yeah but it's also what is right
that's also what is and it's also
innocence at full play there that
there's someone that knows someone that
needs corrected and someone into knowing
someone um you know someone that that is
is proclaims that they know yeah it's a
proclamation right right it's a
proclamation and there's a lot of
characters that does that and that's it
it is what it is right but the uh the
emper uh the character is the um the
emptier the the barricades are
the emptier you know that there's
everything is transparently empty yes
the the uh there's no separation really
and it's just really to Goonies you know
what I'm saying uh gooning it out and
everything gooning it out gooning it out
and and not you know there's no
seriousness anymore and it's really
pointless and it's just the the joy of
just speaking about something that
cannot be spoken about not someone
claiming that they know or you don't
know what you're talking about it's not
about correcting anyone and the seeming
Pitfall for a lot of uh you know seeming
uh characters that come into Clarity is
that when the clarity is just
so
humble it's it's there's nothing that
was attained it's actually
anticlimactic yeah then it seemingly in
the story makes up a knowing um and it
and it proclaims that it knows more now
and only to fall apart again if you see
that right there's many characters that
will claim that they know but they'll
fall apart all over again and it's
coming from a position of I know and you
don't know and and and then and then
when the word god gets thrown around of
when it becomes this ownership now right
then all of a sudden I am God and you're
not and that becomes that becomes the
the idea that is being you know but I
can show you how to to get there but
that's just another made of concept
4399 4399 yeah yeah you can do
installments if you like but
yeah for 5.99 I'll show the nipple
yeah there's another comment in the live
chat thank God he decided to wear a
shirt
today
[Music]
oh just
Goonies it's just really gooning out
it's just this the yeah yeah yeah it's
beautiful yeah yeah there's there's such
an
excitement there's like this gooning out
and there's this excitement about
like you have you seen um what is called
like solar Punk um have you heard of
that it's like a it's like a fascinating
type of um of like futurism that's at
one and in harmony with nature and
meeting basic needs and prosperity and
stuff and so it's sort of one of the
models that's being used at the DA for
and like it's so cool sort of
envisioning like what these like um
these beautiful modern homes that are
lived in and then these amazing natural
communal spaces that are all joyous
goony playful like and just like every
day is just some sort of like un like
and this is it's already the case yeah
and then and then there's also this
like
like it's almost like only only the
energy that is like what was said as
like separation porn or like we we we'll
drop missiles and bombs on your country
CU you're inferior and you're separate
like that that that's sort of the only
thing that's that's that's uh in a
way
um it's not really holding back the
appearance it's not what's happening but
but you get what I'm what is being what
is being said yeah yeah totally yeah it
is what it is no matter what it is
exactly yeah and and to try to to like
even the idea that this is not
unconditional Freedom arising as War
it's also it yeah exactly even even that
like the the that there's so even that
being like you know oh it's also it you
know even that it's like thank thank
goodness that in a way Freedom can arise
this way apparently thank goodness
because it's it it's beautiful to arise
in all of these various ways apparently
yeah yeah that that's what that's what's
often overlooked right is in the search
for Freedom it overlooks what freedom is
it's it's whatever it is is freedom and
and it does not need any kind of um
comprehension or attainment because it's
fre Freedom no matter what it is it's
not the the idea of what freedom is
because that's not freedom because
that's a concept of what freedom is yes
um it's conceptualized Freedom appearing
as whatever it is yes yes
yeah oh
yeah I love it it's not that freedom
will be when basic needs are dentalized
and there's a solar Punk future it's
that this is already Freedom always
already
and yeah and if the body's function
naturally moves towards building that
solar Punk de centralized basic need so
be it it's beautiful you know yeah yeah
and and and and again it's so free that
it can appear as any idea of what
freedom is yes that's how free is
exactly exactly it's so free that it can
appear as as Freedom will be when I've
got my next private planes and um
exactly
possession andain followers that kind
of yeah yeah it it's so tricky right
because you know in the search for
Freedom it it it always always always
always overlooks the freedom that's
looking for freedom is already Freedom
yes so whatever is Looking For Freedom
is already Freedom itself yes yeah
exactly exactly there's really no
separation and and that's that's so mind
boggling right what do you mean this is
already Freedom yeah um this is already
freedom and there's nothing that can be
done to to make it not Freedom you know
what I'm saying because that's just yes
yeah yeah that's another great nothing
can be done to make it not Freedom
exactly yeah or not done yeah yeah yeah
um nothing can happen for this to not be
free yeah yeah
yeah no another funny way it's it's been
said is no amount of meditation or
psychedelics can make this not free or
whatever no amount of trying to move to
get something can make it not free
anyway whatever it's just it's like it's
like playing a chess with Stillness so
any movement is a Checkmate because it's
already
Stillness that's it that's it it's
always that's it that's it that's it um
and and and and in the game of the
Stillness game of Stillness or whatever
um what seem every apparent move is
Checkmate it's right even thought
interesting that's a good way that's a
good way to because every apparent move
is complete yeah fre that's such cuz
Checkmate had been coming up recently
and that's interesting that that's yeah
that's so good usually on a one in one
when they when they can like do a
oneon-one it's it's it's uh it's a
Checkmate the character that it has
nowhere to go that um because it's
nowhere to go right it's
uh yeah yeah oh oh that's it's already
done it's already it's already Checkmate
the moment that they they come in the
picture it's already Checkmate because
there's nowhere to go and there's
nothing to do there's nothing to
understand and every movement every um
any even the idea of moving even any any
kind of hidden idea or agenda to move is
already
Checkmate yeah already is yes
yeah you have a hard out right that's
coming up so yeah yeah let's let's let's
wrap it up
so
um the thank well also thanks I well
that last bit on the checkmating yeah I
love that every every apparent move is
Checkmate it's so so good it's never
possible to leave it's just there's so
many endless ways to say oh yeah and and
and again nothing can can be said about
this that can capture this because
that's a Checkmate because it already is
yeah it already is it always this no
matter what it is yeah yeah and and and
and that's so hard to believe but it's
not about believing it because that's
just another move yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
ah so there's so much excitement about
whatever
will unfold here this yeah this so much
play it is especially Emerson showing
his
nipple I have a third eye nipple so it
might Enlighten people when they show it
so that's why it's 399 yeah yeah yeah
yeah the third
nipple yes
oo well I said this ear ear that you I
would like to invite you to to to the
channel and um we'll continue this
conversation and uh it's just fun it's
just play it's just there's really
nothing that that we achieved here um
yes yeah yes exactly it's just fun play
Goonies and I would love to accept the
invite and come on the program and yeah
yeah for sure we will uh we'll let me
let me end the stream and then you you
and I can wrap uh yeah thank you
everyone for tuning in um wow that was
fun man there was a lot of fun play in
the live chat too Emerson so beautiful
um and uh oh check out the links in the
bio below we have uh the Emerson's
website as well as Emerson's YouTube
channel where you can get absolutely
nothing from exactly
yeah oh all right uh I'll end the stream
much love thanks everyone thank you so
much
everyone